[Musique]
territoire 0 chômeurs de longue durée
c'est d'abord une histoire de carte 10
villages ou quartiers choisis en 2016
pour essayer de ne pas baisser les bras
face au chômage de longue durée un
concept unique à rebours de ce qu'on
apprend dans les écoles de commerce mais
soutenu par des grands noms de
l'économie
on crée de l'emploi pour des personnes
qui veulent travailler dès qu'il ne
trouve pas non plus en fait extrêmement
simple il s'agit de créer des
entreprises localement pour offrir des
emplois à tous les gens qui en sont
privés en clair on ouvre des entreprises
et on invente le travail ensuite en
fonction des envies et des compétences
des salariés on répond à des besoins qui
ne sont pas couverts actuellement côté
salaire c'est le smic pour tous et les
finances publiques s'y retrouveraient à
la place d'un chômage ou d'un rsa soit
18 mille euros en moyenne par an et par
personne
cet argent va à une entreprise à but
d'emplois une bo qui embauchent le
salarié au salaire minimum
[Musique]
seulement ce n'est pas aussi simple dans
la réalité
du côté de la direction comme des
salariés le bea est une aventure
collective avec tout ce que ça comporte
rien des journées où c'est dur quand on
a des problèmes tentant des choses qui
sont compliqués des gens et il y en a
ils ont des vrais vrai problème si vous
venez ici pour rien faire de la tournée
la semaine avec longue mais très long
mais je repasse pas désormais le
dispositif va être élargie à cinq ans
pour vos territoires non je pense à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui s'en exclut aujourd'hui nous
avons fait un super repas
donc j'en suis très très fier voyage de
paris en provence en passant par la
nièvre au pays de ses salariés en voient
de réparation
[Musique]
et
ajoute nous sommes bien en provence à 30
km de la riche ville d'aix mais à une
heure en transport en commun
près de l'opulence du luberon mais loin
de son niveau de vie
depuis trois ans alice théveny frotte
les vitres des commerces de joutes
selon elle la place idéale surtout
comparé à son dernier emploi de femme de
ménage dans une entreprise avant le
chômage jeu sur place j'habite à sa
minute d'ici les horaires on a eu les
horaires choisis en fonction de nos
enfants des écoles des donc voilà c'est
parfait pour les mamans pour un
possibilité
[Musique]
c'était tôt le matin tard le soir
donc en bus avec les horaires de crèche
ou d'école pour les enfants s'est
beaucoup dépensé puis je voyais pas
beaucoup mon fils du couple
alice n'est pas employé par le
commerçant elle travaille en fait pour
l'entreprise à but d'emploi et didier du
sel le boulanger n'a pas hésité une
seconde quand les responsables de la
structure nous des marchés et font des
services que les entreprises privées ne
font plus qu on trouvera pas sûr jouer
et comme c'est un organisme qui s'occupe
d'embaucher des chômeurs qu'il faut les
faire à travailler donc c'est volontiers
qu'on les fait travailler à jouques dans
l'entreprise à but d'emplois
ludwick obouo et le directeur commun
ok jours d'affilée en deux journées
[Musique]
contrairement à la plupart des salariés
lui touche deux fois et demie le smic
car il a été recruté pour ses
compétences des directeurs avant il
travaillait dans le privé et comme avant
il a besoin d'avoir des clients
dernièrement il a décroché un bon marché
pour la mairie de jouques des toilettes
sèches pour le parc municipal dans
l'équipe il a mélangé des anciens et des
nouveaux pour que les uns apprennent des
autres driss fin des dernières entrées
de 2019 il est sur le multi services il
est surtout pour sa compétence en
maçonnerie l'état l'ancien maçon
idrissia l'a 45 ans travaillait avant
dans le bâtiment jean-louis tartaroli 50
ans pas du tout j'avais une entreprise
j'étais dans le désodorisant automobile
gm pourrait croire gt briques il s'est
avoué très bien les vraiment en fait
c'est vous qui le forme et on va dire ça
c'est son deuxième prénom
les gens qui sont troisièmes pas
forcément professionnels du secteur les
salariés d'une baisse sont moins
productifs que dans une entreprise
classique
pour autant le patron facture à la
mairie le prix du marché 7000 euros pour
le chantier on n'est pas beaucoup moins
cher ou beaucoup plus cher parce qu'il
ya le temps de travail valorisé après le
seul truc ouvert on va être différent
c'est par exemple moi je vais avoir
établi un devis sur deux ou trois
personnes
et vu que je vais avoir du temps off ils
vont y aller à cinq ou six parce que ça
va être plus facile ça va être donc pour
ça que c'est difficile de comparer le
prix parce que si je compare est
toujours au nombre de salariés on
devrait être beaucoup plus haut niveau
du tarif ne sais pas le butin
pour faire fonctionner l'entreprise et
ses 46 salariés
ludwig gros doit augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires du travail pour les employés
qui va rapporter de l'argent à
l'entreprise car les subventions ne
suffisent pas alors ici on propose tout
un tas de services à des clients privés
ou à la mairie les travaux de menuiserie
en passant par de la restauration de
meubles ou l'entretien des vélos
ce sont les salariés en collaboration
avec la direction qui ont proposé ses
services des activités à l'imaginer
qu'il ne ferait pas concurrence à une
entreprise du coin c'est la règle pour
les au bo en ce mois de septembre
ludwig rouen va faire le point avec sa
responsable financière signant avec
l'adac maddens évoqué à la date de l'ag
en 2019 on a fait 190 mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires sur l'année
donc tout pour le profond du toutes
activités confondues et en 2020 à fin
août on était à cent mille donc le
compliqué par rapport au budget à monter
parce que ben voilà on fait comme comme
toute entreprise française ont fait face
aux bolides donc compliqué de chiffre
d'affaires maximum pour verser les
salaires
la contribution de l'état ne suffit pas
explications pour chaque smic l'état et
les collectivités versent 1460 euros
mais pour payer totalement le smic et
ses charges sociales soit 1860 euros
l'entreprise va devoir trouver 400 euros
par elle même
et ici le pari est en passe d'être gagné
les activités développées ont presque
permis d'atteindre l'équilibré financier
l'implication de chacun et les
compétences de tout ce sont les clés de
la réussite
à 33 ans ce salarié est diplômé en
images 3d
une pépite pour le bo vient le braz
n'est pas seulement brillant et bien
élevé il est aussi épileptiques
après deux ans de travail dans une
agence de communication
il a dû arrêter ensuite ce fut trois ans
et demi sans emploi et un rsa je sais
beaucoup de crises d'épilepsie
parce qu'on me demandait beaucoup
j'étais surchargé donc allez-y il y ait
eu à passer vite on papa et samassa m'a
vraiment déprimé je me suis vraiment
renfermé sur moi-même je suis plus sorti
chez moi je parle plus à personne
c'était c'était l'enfer parce que
j'étais vraiment énervé j'étais en
colère je j'ai beaucoup souffert en fait
à cause de ma maladie franchement la vie
moi c'est les deux en fait ce qui est
génial avec l'énoncé que entièrement
confiance ça m'a vraiment aidé à
remonter et après en ce qui me concerne
ça a été une renaissance dans quelques
mois
yann se lancera comme auto entrepreneur
dans les e bay eu plus d'une personne
sur quatre embauches et est considéré
comme handicapé et toutes ont une
fracture de vie
un décès une dépendance une violence
l'eau-de-vie gros connaît l'histoire de
chacun et les problèmes de tous ici
c'est lui le patron
mais c'est aussi l'assistance sociale
qui doit composer chaque jour avec les
uns et les autres mais lui on a tiré une
force pour l'entreprise le monde du
privé c'est l'argent qui dirige tout
dans ce paragraphe est l'argent dirige
beaucoup mais l'humain il fait beaucoup
et il est vrai même si c'est dur il ya
des journées où c'est dur tu entends des
problèmes tentant des choses qui sont
compliqués des gens et il y en a ils ont
des vrais vrais problèmes et ça va même
tendance des fois tu heures c'est dur
quoi mais ça te permets moi je me pense
en tout cas plus ouvert et plus pas
compatissant mais j'ai pas le bon terme
dans l'accompagnement des personnes moi
je pense que ça m'a fait évoluer en tout
cas je vois moins les gens 10 ans et
celui là les problèmes ils emmerdent non
s'est il a des problèmes il a des vrais
problèmes
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour lui au
total 64 personnes ont été embauchées 18
ont retrouvé un emploi ailleurs
seulement quatre ont abandonné sur le
papier le bea est une machine à
réinsérer les oublier une machine qui
pourrait faire des émules
en ce jour de rentrée parlementaire une
députée est particulièrement concentrée
elle veut faire voter une proposition de
loi pour que de nouvelles régions
deviennent territoire zéro chômeur
marie-christine verdier joucla et député
du tarn et pour elle il n'y a pas de
doute
le dispositif a un bilan très positif
même si c'est une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan du chômage
[Musique]
vous allez aujourd'hui 900 personnes qui
ont retrouvé un boulot pour la plupart
ils étaient privés depuis à moyenne je
pourrais citer 54 mois d'absence de
travail et ensuite vous avez 660
personnes qui par cette dynamique
finalement à les candidates et mais ont
trouvé un travail dans une entreprise
classique directement
donc elles sont même pas passés par le
béa mais le fait qu'une cette dynamique
sur ce territoire
leur a permis de trouver un travail
c'est déjà très éloignés de l'emploi et
donc c'est pas rien c'est énorme
la députée c'est que depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire
un million de personnes ont basculé dans
la pauvreté alors elle espère que son
texte sera voté à l'unanimité le
lendemain à l'assemblée
le scrutin est clos la députée a
remporté une victoire tant son set
exprimer sans cette majorité 54% cette
recontre égaux dans quelques mois
cinquante nouveaux territoires devrait
être choisi pour bénéficier du
dispositif
quand je pense à toutes celles et tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui s'en exclut
aujourd'hui nous avons fait un super
repas
donc j'en suis très très fier et dont je
voulais simplement voilà vous le dire
pourtant ce consensus politique qui est
percuté par des rapports des services de
l'état
certaines analyses économiques sont très
critiques dans le journal les échos
pierre cahuc un économiste qui a
participé à son lancement averti le coût
d'un emploi ne se limite pas aux
salaires versés
il faut prévoir des frais d'encadrement
et d'investissements immobiliers
de fait un emploi coûterait plus cher
que dans le projet de départ n'ont pas
18 mille euros par salarié embauché
chaque année mais environ 25000 euros
certaines études chiffres eux mêmes à
plus de 30000 euros le coût pour les
finances publiques
[Musique]
marie-christine verdier joucla connaît
les conclusions de ces rapports
d'autant plus qu'ils allaient membre de
la commission des finances
ce jour là elle a rendez-vous avec l'un
des grands artisans de l'expérimentation
laurent grandguillaume ancien député
socialiste laurent grandguillaume est
aujourd'hui le président de
l'association qui pilote le projet et
tous deux expliquent que les finances
publiques doivent assumer le surcoût
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit de dire
que ça coûte de l'argent
mais moi la limite ça me dérange pas
parce que je me dis que j'ai fait je
veux dire il ya des choses qui n'ont pas
de prix donc si ça permet à des
personnes privées durablement d'emplois
même celles qui sont aux radars celle
qu'on appelle les invisibles ou les
ignorer parce qu'elles sont tellement
dépité est long et allemands était déçu
mais qu'elles sont hors champ de tout si
ça leur permet de revenir dans un statut
leur permet d'avoir de nouveau la
dignité de retrouver un travail de se
sentir utile et d'avoir de nouveau
confiance en elle c'est pas grave si ça
coûte de l'argent et laurent
grandguillaume d'insister parce qu'ils
créent des emplois de proximité
ce dispositif a aussi des vertus
environnementales
un combat majeur du moment on se battra
toujours
ce décideur d'écologie société terrain
c'est un cru oui c'est pas con mais
c'est aussi un bénéfice de la société
c'est pas ma v6 même si c'est important
l'important en finançant de nouveau au
bo l'état mis sur des effets à long
terme mais le dispositif remplit-il
l'objectif de redonner le goût du
travail à des chômeurs de longue durée
et à leur redonner confiance
un autre rapport demandé par le
ministère du travail cible 4 b e dont
prémery dans la nièvre où la réalité
décrite est très éloignée de l'utopie de
départ les enquêteurs dépêchés sur place
décrivent des débuts mouvementés les
premiers mois de son fonctionnement ont
notamment été marquée par le départ de
trois directeurs différents
le document pointe du doigt d'une
entreprise toujours à la recherche de
son mode d'organisation
résultat pas celle enthousiasme du
lancement de l'expérimentation un climat
pessimiste s'est installé parmi les
salariés
qu'en est il aujourd'hui prémery ne
s'est jamais remise de la fermeture il y
a quinze ans de la grosse usine locale
en 2017
nos équipes y était allé pour filmer le
vent d'espoir que faisait naître le
projet aujourd'hui nous y avons retrouvé
david redouté 52 ans après cinq ans de
chômage il était l'un des premiers à
avoir été embauché ici mais bien dans le
nord madar libre la cub est ardue que
falcon boulot il y avait déjà un
tournant pas très emballée quand on vole
donc tu content d'avoir mon boulot nous
décidons de le replonger à l'époque de
son entrée à lever eux ont su quand nous
l'avions rencontré en lui faisant
revisionné le reportage de l'époque à
laisser partir
retour en 2010 êtes abonné mais c'est
bien ça plus que sous sa part repasser
par là je pousse fait de sa personne et
ça me touche ça fait combien de temps le
2017 2018 2019 2020
trois ans et vous arrivez encore un
touché quand même mais ben
obama était déjà compte deux ans durant
les 60 ça m'a bien discret tir mais bon
a tancé ces procédures mais c'est passé
alors david at il vu une évolution dans
le fonctionnement de l'entreprise
que fait-il au quotidien y at-il
vraiment du travail ou se contente-t-il
de venir ici pour toucher son salaire
cette année là ça commence à bouger
yak occuper les gens et habile ya du
travail à que travailler donc ça va on
n'est pas y'a du boulot
il ya eu du boulot tué parce qu'avant
c'était pas forcément caire mais c'était
pas tellement le cas on était libre à
nous mêmes n'ont pas les conseils des
meilleurs pour travailler et personne
qui lui donne un planning personne qui
lui disaient voilà tu as affaire où ça
ou ça peut-être maintenant ça a changé
maintenant la même un planning c'est pas
grand chose mais sait on est content et
je dors la bible certains vous dirai
c'est sympa de pas avoir de planning
besoin de faire un nom mais non mais non
même si vous venez ici pour rien faire
de la journée la semaine avec londres
mais très longue mais je repasse pas
sans le b e david qui a encore deux
enfants à charge survivre est tout juste
sept dernières années les choses ont
elles changé comme le dit david ce jour
là les services de l'état veulent s'en
assurer
[Musique]
à
johan pons fait partie des inspecteurs
qui sont venus faire leur rapport pour
le ministère du travail en mai 2019
il est mandaté pour faire une deuxième
évaluation
[Musique]
il interroge d'abord marie-laure brunet
la nouvelle directrice
moi j'ai repris officiellement la
direction au moins déjà pour les 90 à
peu près de toulouse sur site vous
avais-je pas trentaine de personnes
prêtes à temps une directrice qui essaye
d'expliquer aux inspecteurs qu'une bea a
besoin de ton pour se structurer que
tout est question d'équilibré fragile
le but du modèle c'est que ça c'est
qu'il est ok peut-être on arrivera à
trouver effectivement un truc de niche
on a tout un travail qui est en train de
se mener avec quelqu'un qui porte un
projet mais ça ne pourra être que que
sur du long terme
le rapport de mai 2019 soulignait à
l'époque le manque d'activité mais selon
l'inspecteur ce constat était presque
inhérents au concept même de territoire
zéro chômeur territoire zéro chômeur
c'est zéro chômeur ça veut dire que le
but de l'entreprise étant l'emploi son
but c'est d'aller le plus vite possible
à trouver les personnes qui seraient
intéressés éligibles et leur donner un
emploi dans certaines baies que vous
avez des sous en sous l'occupation
chronique ça peut être soit un manque de
compétences pour pouvoir aller plus
avant sur la structuration d'une
activité soit aussi un territoire qui
est lui-même peu solvables depuis
quelques mois à prémery
ça marche beaucoup mieux une recyclerie
a été réorganisé alimenté par des dons
ou des clients viennent flâner acheter
tout est désormais en ordre
l'été il y à du maraîchage un peu toute
l'année du bûcheronnage mais aussi un
atelier qui a été totalement restructuré
ces derniers mois johan pons
l'inspecteur de détail sa collègue s'y
intéressent justement pour leur deuxième
enquête
ils cherchent à savoir si des salariés
ont désormais des instructions claires
de la part de la direction
indispensable pour bien travailler
il y rencontre virginie de brad 37 ans
bonjour on vient vous voir
c'est dans le cadre d'une mission
d'évaluation de l'expérimentation
[Musique]
grâce à ce magasin tout récemment
structurer le bio attire la clientèle
des maisons secondaires nombreuses aux
alentours derrière le magasin il y a le
plus gros changement de prémery
l'atelier mécanique on irait par
désormais plus de trente ans jean chaque
mois et chacun est à son poste
la no 8 en partie le que les hommes tout
ce qui est mécanique en moto petter
rosso deux au delà des questions des
inspecteurs
une grande partie des salariés ici sont
contents selon eux le ps serait un
incroyable moyen de réanimer des
territoires considérés jusqu'alors comme
perdue on a quand même fait un très bel
effort depuis que s'est créé que ça
donnait quand même pas mal de travail
ici dans cette commune et ça a permis de
voyez la motoculture ça faisait plus de
trois ans qui en avait pas ici à prix
alors c'est vrai que ça redonne de
dynamisme dans la ville de conneries et
un peu plus de pouvoir d'achat
dans quelques semaines les enquêteurs
remettront les conclusions de leur
nouveau rapport une donnée une figura
évidemment le chiffre d'affaires de le
bo il a augmenté de 45 % l'année
dernière l'entreprise est ainsi devenu
le premier employeur de la région
alors quels enseignements tirer pour les
50 nouveaux territoires qui vont se
lancer prochainement dans l' aventure ce
matin-là en région parisienne
l'association territoires zéro chômeur
qui pilote le projet a justement son
rendez vous annuel
[Musique]
à la manoeuvre laurent grandguillaume
l'ancien député socialiste qui se bat
depuis 2016 pour le projet il fait
l'inventaire des troupes participant au
dispositif d'aidé
il ya aussi la fédération dakar la
solidarité il ya emmaüs il ya secours
catholique qui appela l'association
formatrice arrête qu'ils sont sont
fédérés et puis des personnes qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas dans des
associations qui sont juste adhérents de
territoire aux chômeurs mais sans son on
va avoir une histoire particulière dans
une association caritative et notamment
un patron qui a construit des avions et
fait rouler des trains
louis gallois président le fonds
d'expérimentation contre le chômage de
longue durée
selon lui les dix territoires déjà
engagés ont eu un vrai rôle de
laboratoire pour les prochains on
démarrera plus si on n'a pas des locaux
parce qu'on a démarré d obéir sans avoir
des locaux
adecco rect dé quoi tu es on en arriver
à des situations qui était absurde
donc il faut qu'il y ait des conditions
matérielles qui sont mises en place
deuxièmement au début on n'a pas
suffisamment insisté sur la formation et
c'est bon aussi pour le mieux parce que
si les personnes sont formées elles sont
plus capables de faire des travaux à
plus forte valeur ajoutée
c'est bon pour l'entreprise c'est bon
pour l'environnement local que les
territoires qui vont se présenter pour
la deuxième phase sont des territoires
qui auront été préparés en utilisant
l'expérience je veux de la première
phase pour tous ici territoire zéro
chômeur mérite d'être élargie car
retrouver du travail
c'est bien plus qu avoir un meilleur
revenu cela signifie aussi donner un
avenir à ses enfants quand on voit ses
parents travaillent et on a la fierté de
voir ses parents travailler et bien on
ose du cou rentré dans les
apprentissages c'est à dire que le
conflit de loyauté qui empêche les
enfants d'apprendre à l'école
il commence à s'effacer et on voit
combien les enfants et les jeunes aux
écouter ce qui leur est proposé et oser
apprendre aux et se projeter dans
l'avenir aussi
et l'association va bientôt accompagner
les nouveaux entrants pour répondre à
des critères précis
partout en france
de nombreuses collectivités locales sont
déjà en train de préparer leur dossier
elles sont nombreuses à vouloir postuler
pour devenir des territoires 0 chômeurs
de longue durée
[Musique]